[Music]
i just say this has been the most
amazing week here in puerto rico so
i'm now going to do a steak sandwich a
beautiful new york strip taking the fat
cap off it lightly seasoned it and then
i'm going to grill it super quick but
the secret here is to make sure we give
some spice some love into that steak
okay and that's why i've got a red mojo
and it's a sort of a staple in pottery
cuisine as a way of injecting some sort
of
you know
flavor but more importantly it gives off
the most amazing
heat as well
now
let that steak sit in the marinade the
secret now has got a really good color
on there
push it down nice and even so you can
flatten out i look at the size of the
bread i think of my steak and so i just
manipulate that steak to the size of the
bread so therefore no one's got any
short ends
push that down
get all that marinade in there and then
straight onto the grill
find the hardest part
and lay that on
beautiful
get that pan nice and hot
and now for the garnish
what goes well with the steak onions
peppers beautiful these a nice white
onion this time round
nice and chunky
again
in
a touch of olive oil
onions in
plentiful
nice
next to that
some red pepper just literally top and
tail it down to the side
and around
now secret here
is to make sure that we
get that
balance of the sweetness
with the beautiful caramelization of
those onions
peppers
sliced nice and thinly it's a steak
sandwich so we're gonna leave the skins
on
nothing wrong with it and they saute
beautifully so
nicely done
beautiful
peppers go in with the onions
all right
turn that steak
beautiful
now
on the first turn
get your morehole and just beautifully
baste that
over the steak
you see this flavor profile
literally
raising the roof
through on generously
nice
let that sit there
and sort of caramelize
beautiful
now once that stakes
turn
again
lift it up
and turn it
and go again
with your hole this time on top
beautiful
we need a really good robust bread
lightly olive all the bread
i've got a nice soft
white roll
pinch it together
and grill that nicely
that's our staple
straight onto the grill
beautiful
once that's toasted bring that back
make sure you've gotten a nice firm bit
for the base
and there's the top really important to
get that color on there
then we'll take the steak off
steak comes off
and then the peppers
once they've caramelized
take
a little touch
of cilantro
chop that up nice and fine
throw that in there
with your peppers
scallions
right at the end and just take the tops
off okay
if they stay on the board that is when
the wind picks up
it takes my tops away go into the steak
sandwich look at that
beautiful
finish that with a touch of seasoning
mix that up
beautiful
now generously
spoon on
the peppers
the onions that freshness with that
little cilantro at the end
the hip beautiful
i want them hanging out the ends i don't
want anyone skimping on that
beautiful
check temperature
it's
medium rare
slice
the bias
up
and sit that in
slice hide up
beautiful
those little bits
are for the dog if you behave himself
mmm
that is amazing a little seasoning in
there
because we've exposed the meat
pepper
lid on
push down hold it nice and firmly
slice down
and there you go a beautiful steak
sandwich pottery can style
the dog i'll eat those little bits this
is for you
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch it on catch
up on disney plus
[Music]